parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
bonjour et bienvenue dans équilibre
votre émission dédiée à l'environnement
dans ce numéro nous vous emmenons à la
découverte d'un des patrimoines de
biodiversité les plus riches d'île de
france pour assouvir les fourni de louis
xiv et approvisionner les fontaines du
château de versailles un réseau d'eau de
600 hectares a été construit au xviie
siècle
aujourd'hui ce réseau existe toujours de
son utilité est tout autre il représente
un habitat produisent pour des centaines
d'espèces sert aux oiseaux insectes
plantes en tout genre de rambouillet à
trappes
nous partons à la découverte de ces
étangs et rigole
et on cendré grèbes huppés poules d'eau
les yvelines sont le terrain de jeu de
centaines d'espèces un patrimoine de
biodiversité qui s'est développé autour
d'un réseau d'étangs et de rigoles de
rambouillet à saint quentin en yvelines
on compte onze plans d'eau tous reliés
les uns aux autres n'y voyez là aucune
prouesse de la nature c'est bien l'homme
qui a conçu artificiellement ce réseau
en 1685
à l'origine il fallait répondre aux
besoins en eau conséquent du château de
versailles
les est en toc les eaux sont alimentés
par des rigoles de collecte l'étang de
la tour est alimenté par exemple par la
rigole de saint benoît qui va collecter
les eaux sur la forêt sur les sur les
terres agricoles
et quand c'est au camp les plans d'eau
sont suffisamment rempli on peut envoyer
les eaux par le grand lit de rivière et
les amener jusqu'à 50 à une prouesse de
gestion altimétriques depuis la fin des
années 70 le réseau s'arrête à l'étang
de saint quentin en yvelines
l'arrivée de la ville nouvelle a rompu
le dernier tronçon l'aqueduc de trappes
une rigole fait le lien entre les
différents et en ce grand lit de rivière
est aussi appelée rigole royal
legrand la rigole sort et si cela à
l'air libre mais sort d'un aqueduc
souterrain et ça c'est très classique
sur le grand lit des rivières est à peu
près la moitié de l'ue linéaire qui est
un aqueduc souterrain et l'autre moitié
qui est en ciel ouvert donc c'est un
aqueduc ans les terres de recouvrement
était trop élevé d'où ces magnifiques
d'aqueduc que l'on a aujourd'hui que
l'on entretient et qui ont aussi une
belle qualité de d'hivernage pour les
chauves souris des populations
chiroptères et on trouve des plusieurs
centaines de chiroptères ici en hiver
que l'on dénombre comme et c'est pas
déranger la population augmenter de 30 à
40 % ces dix dernières années
on compte aujourd'hui près de 400 chauve
souris c'est rigole de liaison permet
surtout de réguler l'ensemble du réseau
et les niveaux d'eau de chaque étang
sais tu rigoles de liaison la grande
rigole qui collectent l'ensemble des
plans d'eau fait 22 km 22 km de distance
entre l'étang de la tour et l'étang de
saint quentin
elle est souvent à sec en était parce
que on ne vit pas les plans d'eau en été
aux gardes maximum d'eau partant dès
l'automne dès la reprise de pluie et se
remplit progressivement elle est surtout
utilisée par nous lorsque l'on fait des
lâchers d'eau pour remonter le niveau
d'eau à saint quentin pendant l'hiver
ces lâchers d'eau s'opère dans les
pavillons de soupape ici celui de
saint-hubert où le système reste
d'époque
le but du réseau c'est de stocker l'eau
comme du temps de louis xiv le stocker
pour leur envoyer par la suite vers les
30 50 ans donc là je veux ouvrir la
vanne
donc en fonction du nombre de tours que
l'on nous on sait exactement le débit
qu'on envoie dans le grand lit de
rivière
si on est à quatre tours on est à 200
litres si on est à deux tours on est à
100 litres on est arrivés tour on est
pratiquement car en période estivale
l'étang de saint quentin père jusqu'à
six centimètres par semaine entre
l'évaporation et l'infiltration de l'eau
son niveau décent généralement sous les
3 m à la fin de l'été soit 80 cm de
moins que son niveau habituel sans
intervention humaine
les temps seraient voués à disparaître
et avec lui tout son écosystème
mais cette régulation demande d
attention particulière par exemple
conserver un niveau suffisant à
saint-hubert pour permettre aux brochets
de se reproduire ils pondent sur les
tiges de ces roseaux sur ses sites les
roselières sont d'ailleurs très protégé
si on regarde sur la rive nord on
s'aperçoit qu'on a donc une une partie
roselière très rapidement une soul et et
après on a un étage supérieur qui est du
bois dur quand généralement de la forêt
or la partie
constitué de sol gagne petit à petit sur
les étangs diminue la roselière et donc
on perd on perd tout intérêt écologique
liée aux roselière depuis 2008 on est
passé d'une gestion purement hydraulique
à une gestion écologique
un comité scientifique a été créé des
spécialistes des oiseaux insectes
plantes se réunissent régulièrement pour
sauvegarder la biodiversité locale pour
protéger les roselières les saules ont
été arrachés et la première année une
soixantaine d'espèces de plantes ont
reconquis le territoire pour s'aperçoit
que des espèces qui était disparue
depuis 1875 sont réapparus sur le site
et des espèces protégées nationale donc
là c'était le jackpot
on s'est fait vraiment fait plaisir et
très dernièrement on reste encore assez
prudent par rapport à la donner mais
d'un point de vue
habib phone on a des espèces qui sont
liées à des roselières très importantes
qui sont qui sont revenus notamment
la panure à moustache voilà et grande
satisfaction il y aurait une
reproduction de pagnes rabou stage donc
sur la chaîne des étangs de saint-hubert
ce qui est une première en ile de france
un peu plus loin la dic de corbin offre
un magnifique point de vue beaucoup de
héron notamment y ont élu domicile
parfois on y croise un cerf ou un
sanglier l'accès aux berges est
interdite alors il faut se montrer
patient
ici c'est comme un spectacle
on est au théâtre il ya la scène donc
les oiseaux les acteurs qui veulent se
montrer se montre à partir de la digue
et derrière il ya les coulisses et on va
jamais dérangé l'acteur dans les
coulisses ici aussi pour protéger les
animaux et les insectes
il a fallu contrer la progression du sol
des chevaux d'une ferme locales sont
mobilisées pour pâturer ils se
nourrissent notamment 2 les corses et
petit appétit
et puis ces arbres on a aussi tenté une
expérience là c'est pas commun avec de
l'âne et on s'aperçoit que ce dernier
est aussi très efficace notamment pour
pour contrer la progression du sol donc
l'objectif à terme c'est vraiment de
mettre un pâturage de juillet à octobre
sur trois ou quatre hectares de zones
humides dont ce réseau de 600 hectares
les pêcheurs et les chasseurs ont aussi
leur place
contrairement à ce que l'on pense ils
permettent de réguler les populations et
leur rôle va même au delà
s'il n'y avait pas eu de chasse sur les
étangs on peut très bien imaginer que
ces milliards ont été fermés boisé
colonisés par le sol les inventaires
écologiques ont été menées dans les
années 90 ont mis en avant l'action
bénéfique des layons de chasse d'un
point de vue botanique
c'est à dire que les chasseurs pour
circuler à l'intérieur des phragmites et
edu roselière passe à l'engin et c'est à
l'intérieur de ces l'ayant de chasse
qu'on trouvait les plantes protégées
de nos jours le réseau s'arrête à la dic
dépeint au niveau de l'étang de saint
quentin en yvelines depuis 1982 la
gestion est passée de l'état au smage r
le syndicat mixte d'aménagement et de
gestion des étangs et rigole président
du conseil général était très attentif à
l'aspect patrimonial et à ne pas laisser
dégradé un un tel joyau un fleuron dans
les yvelines 2 du grand siècle est
également en qualité hydraulique en
qualité écologique et a proposé la
création sur syndicat avec toutes les
communes qui sont riveraines du réseau
au total neuf communes auxquelles
s'ajoutent les départements et l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin
ces acteurs participent aux frais de
fonctionnement un budget de 5 à 600
mille euros dernièrement une grande
opération de maintien des
infrastructures a été lancé pour un coût
de 2 millions et demi d'euros
ici par exemple on restaure une rigole
de liaison entre les étangs de hollande
et saint-hubert
quand cela est possible on évite de
poser des joints les grenouilles lézards
et couleuvres à collier conservancy leur
habitat
le réseau a bien évolué depuis le 17e
siècle d'un simple outil hydraulique
pour assouvir les folies de louis xiv il
est devenu l'un des patrimoines de
biodiversité les plus riches d'île de
france
j'espère que la visite vous a plu on
finit avec quelques idées pour occuper
vos week-ends tout d'abord un stage de
permaculture alors de quoi s'agit-il
c'est un mode de vie qui permet à
l'homme et à la nature de cohabiter de
manière durable l'association sky en
transition permettra d'en découvrir les
concepts et les applications pratiques
attention c'est un stage payant il faut
s'inscrire et puis le 9 novembre vous
pourrez apprendre à cuisiner avec des
plantes sauvages soupe à l'oseille ou
quiche aux orties rendez vous au château
de la madeleine avec stéphane loriot
animateur au parc naturel de la vallée
heureuse
il reste peu de places dépêchez vous et
sachez que des visites sont organisées
chaque trimestre et également sur
demande pour les groupes
c'est la fin de ce magazine merci de
votre fidélité le mois prochain vous
retrouverez un nouveau numéro présenté
par l'un de mes confrères et d'ici là
prenez soin de la planète